here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay we're on the
Internet
dan are our roads going to consist only
of driverless cars within the next 20
years driving I've read about driverless
cars I don't understand them well let me
blow your mind a little bit yeah there's
it's the technology is already largely
sorted the flight hardware the software
it's all sensing equipment the issue
will be getting it through you know it's
got to go through a lot of regulations
but imagine this this is a tempt you
with it
the self-parking automobile you pull up
to the mall you get out of the car you
hit a button on your phone the component
the car drives off and parks itself and
then when you want it to come back you
hit the button the car comes back self
auto valet James Bond huh I did it
really yeah James Bond had a car well we
can all be James Bond one day and it was
Austin Powers and also here's it and
here's a beautiful thing when you have
cars cooperating v2v communication
vehicle to vehicle communication they
can squadron together they can platoon
together on highways reducing congestion
increasing the carrying capacity of
highways reducing fuel consumption and
that's the real pro and by making them
electronically crash proof they can be
lighter and so they can consume less
fuel so it's a it's a cascade of virtues
with the autonomous cars and the left
lane bandits can be forever convey you
either when you I absolutely you can
blow them off if you like with your
Porsche right yeah all right wait
I'm just finding this okay I mean like
if a person runs out in front of this
car the car will know are generally
speaking the car will react much faster
than a human can
that's a given yeah and and that's the
thing I mean most accidents are caused
by driver error or driver misjudged or
and this would you could zero that out
and the technology is very robust it
will be and what year are we looking at
to have this well I drove a car to this
year that has many of the precursor
systems it has figured that's your
business I mean well you buy this car
and and Beverly Hills it's a
lane-keeping and distance following
radar it has a navigation system it
knows where it is at all times
integrating these systems will not be a
high technical threshold and the state
of Nevada has already licensed those
kinds of vehicles to operate on their
state highways okay
will the Schumer Rubio immigration bill
I didn't know that's what I guess that's
what it's called
yeah the immigration bill they passed in
the Senate will it pass in the house how
could it John Boehner says he's not even
gonna bring it up for a vote
he you're not gonna take up that
specific bill it doesn't sound like but
I think they are going to attempt some
kind of Republican bill that will get
through the house this is already this
is some what's wrong with our situation
in this country it's already such a
Republican bill it's already
ridiculously close evil ridiculously
cruel to immigrants for no reason that
the path to citizenship takes thirteen
years and oh by the way we shoot you
first because well there's there's at
the Texas policy that's the Texas policy
absolutely
I mean John McCain himself said you know
if you don't think this has enough
border security in it then border
security really isn't what you're
worried about it's just a swage racist
this bill I think one of the big
questions is so there's this business
trend in Washington in recent years
where everybody loves to do these
comprehensive bills where you try to put
in a thing that'll make you happy and a
thing that'll make you happy in a thing
that'll make you happy we package it
into one thousand-page bill and then we
see if we can get it to pass and so
there's a lot for people to like in the
Senate bill but then once it makes it
over to the house people could find the
things that they don't like and the fact
that it's a thousand-page bill sometimes
what could they like on the conservative
side it that's right a citizenship what
path right assault dare you limit away
word available that's it there are
significant limits it takes 5-10 years
it said 13 years the pathway there are
significant limits on the number of
high-tech immigrants that could come in
from India and China who have
engineering and scientific skills that
we want to tap it
well--that's fiddling at this our bill
this bill places exact unitive limits on
those kinds of things in it okay so no
this is a bill that's supported by the
tech community by the Chamber of
Commerce by the afl-cio by the
evangelical all justices characters are
all really like this bill monument
Communications has been in touch with
people who are complaining in the
high-tech community that this bill
doesn't address their needs but what I
mentioned a second thing and that is in
more than a decade of working on the
hill I've actually never seen a major
landmark piece of legislation come from
the Senate and just get a single up or
down vote in the house you always gonna
mention quick mega it gets brought
what's that it gets brought john bainer
goes by this coming over they can't stop
that rule that's just a regular rule it
comes over the question is what does the
house pair it up what is that and you're
gonna go into motion has there ever been
a lamer speaker than john bainer I mean
this guy cannot mean thinner god
he does have a hard job didn't wash me
to a further job in John Bainer
I think you Obama I feel really sorry
for John Barrack Obama has to deal with
these mental midgets on your le basis so
yes I would say what I would say and you
had you you challenged me on this my
feeling is that this because of the
political gerrymandering in the house
they have created this this group of
just absolute of troglodytes who won't
vote for anything anyway and so without
them you cannot achieve the Hastert
threshold and so nothing nothing is
getting done no matter what it is and
the bill from the Senate the immigration
bill from the Senate is a crappy bill
I hope they vote it down because we have
to start over again and it's all the 11
million people why why 40 you could give
everybody $2,000 a piece to leave the
country and you still have plenty of
change left over I mean it's only 11
million people okay Adrian what is it
about the documentary film medium that
mobilizes people well I think it's only
just beginning to I mean for so long
it's been marginalized and now you know
people are starting to make more
interesting documentaries I think more
accessible to more people so and that's
what we've been trying to do is really
get people excited you know not just the
dock lovers but everybody mainstream
well don't don't get your hopes up for
an Oscar because they're like so far
behind in this category like anything
that people actually see won't even get
nominated I know this because mine
didn't Michael Moore's didn't Michael
Moore's the the one he did a capitalism
a love story you know didn't even get
nominated because it's always about you
know some I don't know some Latvian well
you could settle for wealth and fame
yeah so I I should go back to that I
think maybe the entourage movie
oh the entourage movie
dan is there any reason Tesla shouldn't
be allowed to sell their cars directly
to consumers right I hear they can't do
that in Texas the place that hates
regulations yeah well it's not just
Texas all 50 states have very
protectionist franchise rules
and it's easy and it's about the fact
that Tesla doesn't has a business model
where they don't sell directly through a
dealer right that's right the the
franchise rules in the states say you
have to go through an authorized license
third party and this was a way to sort
of protect their their business so you
can't buy a car directly from General
Motors or Ford Tesla has a different
business model a different product
really you know an electric car doesn't
need gas and oil and sort of the
attentive service of a dealership which
is the putative reason why the the
franchise rules were written like that
in the first place but Texas is supposed
to be the state that hates regulation
right where your figure than anybody
else it's completely inconsistent well
that's why I think that eventually we're
going to see this change and Texas is
probably going to be among the first
part of what we're going to see in the
21st century is a change so that the
kinds of things like cars or whether
they're electric or otherwise are going
to be able to be purchased online the
same way that you can do a washing
machine or a television or anything
Texas but is on the cutting edge of
those kinds of things in other arid as
if now they'll be behind if they don't
change what they're doing they will ship
what they're doing is they're protecting
needless middlemen just like you know
the National Association of dealers of
America that's right their rival agents
there's another one like that actually
you know you don't really need a lot of
travel agents anymore sorry travel
agents but you know but I think real
estate agents you know you can sell a
house just do somebody without it
somebody in the middle but they want to
get their cut so it's not really freedom
I agree with you but I think the change
is coming because people can see they
can do so many important things in other
areas without a middleman why doesn't
anyone here okay well we don't need
middlemen we're going on vacation thank
you folks thank you pedal
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10:00 ask bill and his guests to her
questions right after the show at
hbo.com